today in our school matters series we're
looking at how teachers are feeling at
the start of the school year from seeing
kids in the classroom again to creating
lessons designed to get them up to speed
chris sanchez known as mr k to his
students teaches kindergarten in los
angeles and he taught virtually last
year but he's now back in his classroom
with 29 youngsters mr kay shows us now
how he's helping students feel supported
during the pandemic
ready set count one
two three the pandemic itself was
extremely challenging on teachers we had
to make huge adjustments to the
curriculum going into this year now that
we're in person it's really teaching at
their grade level and finding ways to
creatively incorporate things that they
might have not learned last year i could
say all right everyone let's count with
me and just take a look at which
students are super excited to count
because they know and maybe which
students are a little bit closed off
because they don't know their numbers
we've been working with math tools this
year's been a little different than
years prior sound good these students
haven't had preschool if there is a
topic they don't understand or know it's
really great to address it in the moment
have them repeat it and then they learn
it you trust
very good i think the topic of holding
students back has to be a decision
that's not made by just one person but
as a unit it's math time it's math time
teaching kindergarten brings so much joy
and i want them to leave me knowing how
to read falling in love with their
favorite story book how to count to 100
you'll hear the phrase you never forget
your kindergarten teacher i think
kindergarten is such a huge pivotal year
for students we're setting them up for
the rest of their time in their
educational journey i am incredible
mr k okay
like him we do like him and we are
joined now by another mr k uh saul khan
the founder and ceo of khan academy it's
a non-profit that offers free education
lessons online and it's excellent i use
it all the time even for grown-up things
uh saul nice to see you again um so we
know things are not good out there in
the land of learning and parents are
trying to help their their youngsters
pick up some ground before the school
year how can they do that best
yeah the reality is even before the
pandemic in a class of 29 or 30 students
like we just saw there's a huge spread
of students some kids are ready to move
ahead some kids need a little bit more
help filling their foundations we know
that as we get back to school now
there's going to be even a bigger
variation in students a lot of students
will need some significant help while
some kids are ready to continue at grade
level or beyond so my recommendation for
parents wherever your child is on that
spectrum try to supplement with other
things and that's why khan academy
exists everything i talk about is free
funded by philanthropy work on khan
academy 20 minutes a day especially in
math we have 50 efficacy studies that it
can significantly grow students khan
academy kids is an early learning app
where students we've had a
umass study where students spend 20
minutes a day these are two to
eight-year-olds so this is early
learning and they're able to close the
gap between kids in the bottom quartile
and kids who are operating at the median
we also have an initiative another
not-for-profit all free called
schoolhouse.world free tutoring yes free
tutoring where people can go and we do
it through having high quality vetted
volunteers but we have a lot of capacity
for more students that's for 13 and over
that's in math and science and sat prep
right now but it's these types of things
that if you supplement it on top of what
you're doing in school 20 minutes a day
doesn't have to be some huge
intervention that'll give you that
security that if your kid's ready to
move ahead and that the class has to
slow down to to meet some of the other
kids needs your student will be fine or
if your class needs to continue at grade
level while your student needs some gap
feeling or finish some unfinished
learning then you're going to be okay as
well so if a kid is not ready to move
ahead is still having difficulty despite
these interventions and parents are
talking about this kind of right now so
that's why i want to ask you should
should a child be held back if they're
still struggling
you know i've written a lot about this
the hard question here is that in the
traditional school model we have
academics and social progression happen
at the same time and if it was just
about academics i'm a big believer in
mastery learning that you should be able
to have the opportunity and incentive to
fill any gaps that you might have but
the problem is it has all sorts of other
social consequences so as a parent or as
an educator i would try my best to do
whatever gap filling remediation
if you use schoolhouse for tutoring use
khan academy get whatever help you can
most school districts have intervention
programs so that you can keep your
student with their cohort and a lot of
students are in the same boat this year
so i think the the school will be very
accommodating of that all right sal khan
thank you so much for joining us this
morning we do appreciate it a lot of
good advice there